turns out to be a nice night here once
again in pittsburgh
and for the pirates chase the young
here's your pennsylvania lottery numbers
acuna smokes that into center field on a
two-strike count
and the braves lead off man is on to
start the series in pittsburgh here's
freddie freeman
last 11 games he is sizzling hot
freeman has a bullet hitting to the
right field corner that's down for a hit
ronald streaks around second on his way
to third ron washington is going to wave
it here comes ronald to the plate
he's going to score standing up and the
brave strike with back-to-back hits in
the first inning
it's one to nothing
[Applause]
and he just took ball four first and
second one out for dansby
chase for chase the 2-2 pitch
ah to get his hand for the bat
already is making his way to first he's
hit on the hand and that's going to load
the bases
hard hit but at the short stop
newman well you talk about working hard
max freed the lefty five and four four
sixteen era
and there he is he's an all-star
one-two and a breaking ball of beauty
max free
takes care of reynolds and the pitch
did he go yes he did
stallings is wrong up and max fried is
out of the first
last 15 games he's 5-4-47
swings and pops one up right side
and it'll be phillip evans the right
fielder there make the catch one out
[Applause]
yeah good work striking out
opunya disagreeing
with corey blazer one two three for
chase de young
and another swing and a miss freight's
got his third strikeout gamel's retired
the payoff is bounced to the left side
riley's got it good play
and that will retire the pirates in
order first one two three inning for max
freed
here's how the bases loaded but could
not push across a second run let's see
how they do
with the young here that ball is
launched deep toward left center at 410
and camel and reynolds look at each
other nobody makes the play
and freeman has a leadoff double
he smokes this ball to center field back
goes reynolds to the warning track
and that'll be plenty deep enough to
advance freddie freeman
ozzy picks on the first pitch productive
out 3-0 pitch
and riley takes another walk two of
those first and
third for atlanta and here's dansby
bounce to third there's one and two
beautiful well done chase de young
chopper and base hit
gets it down
and gets the out
[Applause]
he's aboard the second time
and then toward right
look at this throw and gets away
and that will allow at least another
runner to move up frazier but wow acuna
unloaded
[Applause]
and he got him to swing and miss
diving stop hayes to his feet there he
is
he brian hayes robs arcia two outs
braves batting in the fourth the pitch
swinging a
miss he struck him out
[Applause]
oh man well done that's great about
camel struck out in the second
camel drives one to deep center field
sending heredia back to the track and
clear the deck with a gamble cannonball
to give the bucks the lead ben gavel's
fifth how about that
how hot is this guy ben gamer
a bullet on the first pitch that's
headed for the left center field gap
ronald around first slams on the brakes
good play by reynolds to get to it
quickly and that's the first braves hit
since the
start of the third inning when freddie
freeman doubled
not going this time and that helps him
get
one and almost two
there he goes pitch is high ball four
inning continues
fly ball to center field sending
reynolds back to the track
and you have to tip your cap to chase to
young he's still
fired up and why not
chase the young you know he battled
through five
and gives way to the bullpen with the
one run lead
clay holmes shieley's numbers 433 era
and 36 appearances
and gets the chase 96.
here's the 01. swinging a hard ground
ball right to short
kevin newman up with it cleanly as he's
done all year
[Applause]
high chopper gonna get infield hit maybe
oh a little bobble
by ozzy albies it's gonna be a base hit
line drive bullet into left center field
reynolds will head to third and into
second
with a rip roaring double as jacob
stallings
as john nagowski he's making his first
pirate start
and how about the big nagowski
it through the left side welcome to the
berg
no-go ben gamel who homered in the
fourth
and this is pulled down the right field
line and this ball
is fair off the wall ben
gamel's got it going double
pirates lead it 4-1
edgar santana the former pirate now
takes the hill
as the bucks chase max freed nobody out
second and third infield comes in
as that's a swing and a miss in a big
out the first of the inning
tap toward third and a play toward first
and the out recorded there
give evans an rbi as nagowski scores
it's 5-1
and he will face frazier
[Applause]
uh-oh this will score a run
pops out of contreras mitt and the
pirates take
a 6-1 lead
[Applause]
[Music]
and bounced and through
polanco still not running at full speed
by any stretch of the imagination
have the bases loaded also a wild pitch
that brought home a run
and it is indeed one last pitch santana
walks over to be
checked out pittsburgh scores four in
the sixth
three balls in a strike and there's a
start adrianzo with a walk
oh sam howard has to love that
[Applause]
oh he wears one on the elbow oh two to
albies
hey he got him struck out three
[Applause]
hey how about stallings last two times
up
hitting it hard how about
the big nagowski
[Applause]
first and second nobody out here is ben
gamel
and drives one deep to center field
heredia back and look at this
ben gamel a two-homer night
big red clears the deck
[Applause]
what a night what a buckle
and riley shoots one towards center and
that's going to drop in for a base head
and dansby lashes that to third keep
ryan hayes long throw
and not in time in fieldhead
[Applause]
bouncing ball hayes one
two double play
[Applause]
look at this great ah is he fun to watch
frasier keep ryan hayes now
one for four
and his sister deep right field opposite
field for key brian hayes
clear the neck with a cannonball for
young hayes
his fourth bucks
busted out against the bravos
11-1 pittsburgh good call john
when you're pulling off the ball you're
not doing that either